We are here with Eric Stonestreet.
And here with us as well, the charcuterie queen,
AKA Corinna Cafarelli.
(audience applauds)
I am so excited.
This is such a good education for me right now.
It's gonna be good.
And Eric, you did a rose salami challenge
recently with your fiance.
Yeah, mine turned out terrible.
Hers was actually like pretty impressive.
So teach us not only how to do the rose,
but how to be less intimidated
by making your own charcuterie board,
which is just such a game changer of a treat for everybody.
Oh yes, I'm so excited to show you guys.
So we're definitely gonna show with the rose first.
Star of the show.
How do we do it?
So, what we're gonna do
is we're gonna take the first piece of salami
just like this, and we're just gonna kinda
hug it around the glass.
Then what we're gonna do is we're gonna repeat this
all around the glass.
Overlapping?
Yep, overlapping.
So taking another piece, overlapping.
Just all around the glass.
This would be a great rim for a bloody Mary.
Yes, honestly.
I feel like they have like sausages
hanging out of bloody Marys, Eric.
They do, I actually just went somewhere
where they had that.
Drew, this is a family show.
(audience laughs)
Perfect, so once we have the first like, round of it,
we're gonna-
We're a modern family.
Yes, we are.
Okay.
We're gonna take the second layer
and do the exact same thing.
So we're just gonna keep going.
Okay, this is monotonous.
Do you wanna like then go in where you didn't,
or follow the exact same line?
You can manipulate it so if you want,
you can go on the opposite side of the line.
Yeah, I feel like filling it.
Like bricks.
Yeah, exactly.
I feel like
covering the seams.
Perfect.
Are we going for a third layer?
We're going, we're going for it because you know what?
The more pieces you pick,
the bigger the rose is gonna look on the board.
So you want it to look really nice and full.
Alrighty, so now this is the fun step.
So we're gonna move the plate out of the way.
So you wanna kinda look at the board and say,
all right, where are we gonna put this rose?
And you wanna kind of be the center of attention.
So we're gonna put it right in the middle.
So what we're gonna do is we're gonna take it
and flip it right over.
And you get the perfect salami rose.
See? Look at that.
You did it.
Perfect.
Oh no.
Perfect!
Perfect.
(audience applauds)
See? Look at that.
Oh my God, we just made this.
Yeah.
Isn't it amazing?
I feel so proud.
(audience applauds)
Yeah, you take a little piece and just-
All right, now that we've got our centerpiece,
like what would you do next?
Now we're gonna go to the prosciutto.
Yeah!
With the prosciutto, sometimes you get
pieces of prosciutto that are a little annoying.
So I'm gonna show you.
I'm gonna show you pieces that you could just
plate them down really nicely.
So what we're gonna do is just take them
'cause these are folded perfectly.
But sometimes you do get pieces that are a little weird,
but what you're gonna do just plate it right around.
You're doing perfect.
Oh no.
Now I'm going on my own.
Now I'm marching to my own drum.
But that's the beauty of it.
You could do whatever you want.
So after this, we can go with some fruit.
Yeah, but I'm not an expert here
What am I doing?
You are.
Listen, you are an expert.
Now what?
So what we're gonna do is we're gonna take the fruit,
and this is where I really like to play with color
and add color onto the board.
And that's where you're really gonna make the board pop.
So what you're gonna do is take your fruit,
you're gonna take some oranges, some Kiwis.
Citrus season is right now so that's perfect.
Okay, oranges, Kiwis, where?
Okay. Next.
Perfect. Get that in there.
I'm making my board pop.
So now what we're gonna do
is we're gonna play with the cheese a little bit.
All right, so brie.
You have it super creamy.
This is like perfect right now to eat
because it's optimum temperature.
You always wanna eat your cheese in charcuterie board
at room temperature.
Yes.
Okay.
So what we're gonna do, I'm actually gonna plate that
right next to our salami rose.
Because I know that the Brie and the salami
is gonna go really perfect together later on.
I love Brie.
I could spread it on anything.
Oh me too.
So now what we're gonna do is we're gonna play
with a little bit of flavor and go on with this fig jam.
Have you ever had fig jam?
Yes, I love it.
Love fig jam.
Okay, have you ever put fig jam
with a little bit of Brie
and a little bit of salami?
Yes.
So you guys know.
I eat many
charcuterie boards.
Yeah, you got it.
So look at that.
You have it hugging right there.
So when you have people going in later on.
No, but that's perfect.
You have it right there with the brie and the fig jam.
So it's easy for people to go in
and get that really perfect bite.
So after that, we're gonna take some crackers.
I love these crackers.
They have a little-
Oh, yeah.
They're super crunchy.
I could eat
Yeah, these are
50 billion of them.
the best crackers.
They're super crunchy, they taste really nice
and they go perfect with the prosciutto, the brie,
the salami, and the fig jam.
Oh, dates. I love dates.
You like dates, Eric?
I love dates.
Me too.
Yep.
I'm telling you,
we have twin tongues.
Put them on the board.
Okay, what'd you put on the dates?
So we did the dates next.
Perfect.
And then what we can do always the last step.
What I like to do is go in.
Eat it.
Well, before that we always have to go
with a little bit a garnish.
So what I like to do is I like to kinda keep it
near the salami to make it look like it's a little stem
coming out of the salami.
So what I like to do is just plate the Rosemary
just like that.
And you can even put it right in the front like so.
Let's see. I love that.
That looks perfect.
Thank you.
Hey, you know what?
Mine doesn't suck.
No, absolutely not.
They look beautiful.
Look at that.
(audience applauds)
It looks perfect.
Yeah.
Mine's pretty nutty.
I'm actually like-
I love it.
I gotta tell ya, I feel really good.
They look beautiful.
I'm not an over confident person.
No, you should be especially after making that.
I feel good about this.
Absolutely, and it's on a lazy Susan.
So you could spin it around for your guests to enjoy.
Eric. Oh, Eric.
Yours looks beautiful.
That looks amazing.
See, got all the colors.
I love adding the oranges.
It looks beautiful.
You know what I see when I see yours?
What?
Bountiful.
Mm, thank you.
That's what a lot of people call me.
Absolutely beautiful.
Bountiful.
(upbeat bright music)